we are going to die and that makes us  the lucky ones most people are never  going to die because they are never  going to be born experiencing life in  its totalities a challenging Endeavor we  become entangled in the trivial issues  of The Daily Grind and we fail to  recognize the vastness of various  experiences life can offer ego is the  enemy here and it creates a trap we  desperately failed to sin this ego trap  is omnipresent and thus our willingness  to reach self-transcendence becomes a  distant hope nature identified this  conundrum early on in his life and  realized how much of an impact it can  have on limiting one's perception